- [Voiceover] Are you a hot mess mom?
Do you have a hard time keeping your
(beep)
together?
Well, you're in luck.
We have some brilliant solutions
to help you hack your way through life.
(upbeat music)
Wear leggings and t-shirts to bed
so you don't have to change in the AM.
You're ready for the school run.
Multitasking is your friend.
Brush your teeth and check social media
while on the toilet.
Eat off of paper towels so you
don't have to do the dishes.
Doubles as a napkin.
Eat while you breastfeed,
don't worry about those crumbs.
Yep, you can use that to wipe your hands.
Sure.
Kids waking you up at the
(beep)
crack of dawn?
Go for it.
Haven't you forgotten something?
Deodorant?
It's okay, baby wipes will do.
Oh, and they'll also wipe
off that stain right there.
You didn't wash your face?
Baby wipes for that too.
Who has time for baking?
Not you.
Buy store bought cupcakes
and smear the frosting
around to look home baked.
(beep)
Forgot to shave your legs,
keep a razor in your car.
- Ah, this kind of hurts.
- [Voiceover] Well then
you should have got you
(beep)
together and taken a shower.
- Nope, never mind, it
doesn't hurt that bad.
- [Voiceover] Share day always creeps up
at an unexpected moment,
so keep toys in your purse at all times.
You've had a long day,
assign the boring books to your partner.
- Oh honey, give it to Daddy.
He loves these really long stories.
Now you're ready to take on the world,
and time manage the
(beep)
out of your life.
Go forth and conquer.
(upbeat music)